est-il vrai qu'il ne vous a pas dit qu'il
allait se présenter à la présidence,
il a oublié que
je ne riais pas tellement
[Musique] la
première dame est-il vrai qu'il ne
vous a pas dit qu'il allait se présenter à la
présidence,
dites  à travers dire vrai
il a oublié il a
oublié que
tu as oublié de dire à ta femme que tu es
candidat à la présidence chaque jour il
pensait
que c'était le jour où je
devrais lui dire tu sais j'ai vu son
adresse du nouvel an et j'ai découvert qu'il était
en fait  courir attendez une minute
vous avez découvert à la télé
vraiment il était c'est
votre opportunité de vous excuser auprès de
votre femme d'accord
[Musique]
qu'en est-il de l'Amérique extrêmement important
ils ont donné des milliards de dollars pour
aider vos efforts
mais le président biden n'a pas été en
ukraine  mais voudriez-vous qu'il vienne
ouais
je crois que ce serait un grand signal un
grand signal
tout le monde voit l'attitude de l'ukraine envers
les états-unis
ce serait le plus grand soutien